give it my leg for that catch it was a  catch we should have four wins hmm screw  it it's time I take this to challenge  Court okay proceed receivers and corners  of the jury exhibit a not as mr. Miller  but gain full control  okay now technically the rule states  that an order for a football move but  now they changed I need to be 2 feet in  big question what is the ground potion  he never became a runner so therefore  not a catch man what the [ __ ] does that  mean  I kid it is no I'm not some Hot Shot TV  Ref I'm a man of the people  so my first witness is 100 guys at a bar  gentlemen was that a can oh yeah that's  a cat does not fall catches the comb  jewelry have you come to a decision yeah  we've decided we have no idea what it  catches well in that case the NFL  defaults to the less fun option no catch  all right next up Jerry Jones for  treason you were sent so much football  those guys